[Music]
something I
so you you have to spiral rotate the
fight and the spiral rotation is in
kiasa so it's in IIT okay don't blow
things out of proportion it's not that
I'm going to fight with Kona or II Tyson
but I can work on the
concepts of how do I spiral rotate the
fight which is another way of saying how
do I bring the opponent into the spiral
rotation you see that well I can force
them into it but that's not
Jiu-Jitsu or I can non-contest you into
it okay so we know he's going to grit
and already have a contestation okay
let's make that a ski that's not going
to be
right so when he skis I move out of the
way this way you see so I'm in this
stance and I take the back foot and I
move it off to this angle and that takes
the Target that he's trying to hit and
stay there and I move it and it's out of
the
way does that make sense okay so I'm not
going over
here I'm not staying on the
line I rotate
me I don't contest I move the
target okay and now I'm over here I'm
over here to him for him to continue to
assault he has to turn towards me do you
see
and that is where you
get the final
rotation rotation I moved me in a way
that for him to continue the assault he
puts himself into this spir rotation
make sense okay so here we are at
io on and this
grip is kind of a
tactile training tool for everything
that I just did in terms of the overall
mine what's everything I did I cleared
the line I did it at an angle where he
would have to spiral rotate
himself and he would have to spiral
rotate himself in a way that I could
move with EDI and he would be in the
centrifugal energy of the SP rotation do
do you get it okay so that's all
happening at this
point so as he comes in I've already
moved we're not we're not
doing this
stuff I am not trying to move
him this one I moov me
so when I move me and then I
enter there's the enter so I
move
me then I
enter I move
me the adhesion kicks
in and I
iner this is a long
way from
this okay but it is also different from
the stepping stone I had you
do from
that there it is then
I okay
TR I don't want go to the 9 I don't want
to go over here to
3:00 there too much of a
flank so if we
were let's say we're spying okay pick
whatever side you want forward and then
he gets to the 90 somehow I'm going to
I'm attack he gets to the 90 okay you
see that I'm not going to face him it's
too long you're going to come out
it's no different than if you feel your
back being taken in
Nea you don't keep turning towards him
you're going to get your back taken you
got to get your back out of there okay
so you're not going to
here this is too too much where a
fighter would get
out okay come back where you are
and that this is equally wrong which is
why you have to bring him
back to this angle again when you do t
uh kinoa you see if you you did a tank
on you're going to have to come back to
this 45° angle you can't be back
here but I can't go to S90 either
I mat this
45 you're right here his inclination is
going to be turn even to look at me he
Thro at me he went into the spiral okay
only only ik UK go like that do do you
understand so I'm here and you do the
move and they like over here like that
everyone else looks do you see and then
they want this straight angle again
okay so think about it don't just do
this movement this is the wrong
geometry you hit here
okay you have this you feel the
contestation yes okay so pay attention
watch what I do it's kind of back and
yielding so my front foot is moving
my back foot is
moving and my hips
are
rotating too small contestant yes you
were at the diagonal but you're
contesting so you want to contest less
now you're too far
back okay it's a timing
thing which it would be in boxing can't
I too
late it's in motion look how you
[Music]
yield
yeld
in
y
y in okay and this is important because
this Ed me
is never long enough do you see in the
in the old version that everyone does
this be me I can't get to the back which
is why a lot of times you see them take
a lot of
steps
okay because Emi can't
happen which being closing the entire
Gap and we know that from our single
legs and our double legs the guut has to
be moving towards me okay for my EDI to
get me to where I want to be so likewise
he's going past me when I ENT turn this
is how Ed Works boom boom if you pay
attention let's see if I can get to the
back from
here that's a huge
step and then watch how little my step
is
when I entered there and now I'm on the
other side of his spine where
before I was actually on this side of
this I got all the way back here do it
again two dimensional one oh look at the
size of that
step and I am forward his spine I didn't
even get to the back
the other one boom boom a little step
and I'm way on the other side of his SP
okay
try don't want to lose the spiral okay
so I don't want to come here and I'm on
the back and I'm looking here see look
my spine straight
here it's not going to be like I'm going
to do the rear naked or suplex or
anything like that
so as we're going I have one more turn
to do on
me so that I am still turning into the
spiral so I'm not Square to
him I'm still lay H me this way there's
a forwardness to my orientation not a
squared to him
one more
[Music]
turn and this this way is where we're
going not
here try let's go back a little okay so
watch his
hand was going
straight but I know I want him to follow
rotate and I said this hand is
your your training aspect
okay
so I don't want his hand to go this
way you see that so when I go here look
every slightly came just
like if
him here then I'm pulling
him so as he's going I will make my hand
do this just keep I'm not going to move
I'm doing
that my hand is not going to be here on
this line just like my head isn't going
to be here my head is going to move you
see I'm not going to let him touch my
head and then I go spiral
rotate as he's going I'm already moving
off that line here I am at that same
angle okay the grip is the same my arm
is
not here anymore it is slightly here
which means his hand is slightly here
this direction so pay attention you
see other way
it's going that way so if I stay here I
move my arm your hand went closer North
more North you see that stay there if my
hand goes here your hands moov in more
south and so slightly got
it so make sure you're not going that
way cuz I want you to go this way so I'm
going that way it's ever so slight
ever so
slightly it's not
this just like punch this isn't it he's
punching right at the last second I move
right at the last second right
here I'm not leading you and you follow
it and he's going to get
that inside his grip I'm timing it so
that it never goes that way does that
make sense yes okay
then let's say we're here we'll slow
down when I do this I don't want to take
what I created and
uncreated so his hand is not here his
hand was here about there and I was here
so when I do say when I do my
Tachi of gon my hand will not go back to
that
distance okay so uh shifting which way
is your hand going south or north south
South you see and now I'm bringing this
and this hand is coming more south you
see then I take the adhesion and it's
going south
so this way you see can you see that now
just watch his hand it's constantly
going south for us is that way in the
doo it's going South it's going south
comes around okay so let's go back and
try to back a little bit
more here's where I am
pay attention now to what you feel pay
attention the energy stop okay but
that's what you're going to feel at
first you're going to feel you're going
to
feel that
flatness okay got it feel for that we do
it with the
energy there it
is do it
again right
there you feel that flatness yes okay
now you're going to pay attention to
where you feel the flatness you have
this little bone right here
there's your arm that bone right there
there's your elbow tip there's the bone
right there and there's an a ledge do
you feel that ledge Yes okay now watch
how that flatness is on that ledge right
there you feel that
yes right
there and at that angle and at that
moment that led is pretty sharp to what
I'm doing got it okay one there's the
ledge
okay next thing you want to feel we're
going to go slow again there's no energy
it'll be fine there's the ledge right
there and now it starts to not be as
perpendicular to my to my action you
feel that yes go back a little and
you'll feel or Y there at that ledge but
as you start to go forward it's coming
off do you see yes then you feel my
thumb in the
technique okay watch now for my
thumb okay LGE
thumb see
okay come on this side and make sure you
get my thumb
camera one
thumbs not together thumbs not together
boom there's the
thumb
boom don't think I'm doing
this I'm Not underneath your hand am M
no s not under here and trying to do
that I am on the side just right
there pull your sleeve up
I am on the outside of his arm you see
here so that he can't come back at
me if I'm here underneath it's easy to
spill over and give me a wrist lock do
you
see so I'm here on the
side boom boom now pay attention
it's going to be over
here you you you want to see my hand
work is what we're focusing on I know
you can't see it here but you
will there is going to be that
ledge let's say viability
there it got light now do you see then
the thumb picks up the thumb has the
viability now pay
attention let's do it again don't do
anything cuz we're not moving don't do
anything just there by
ability off thumbs on you
see say why' you do
that just just don't do anything just
feel
it there goes it's now soft there and
the thumb's becoming hard the pressure
okay I'm not telling you to stop to uh
to resist the technique either don't do
anything means also don't try to stop it
I want you to feel it yes just let it
take you and eventually you feel it go
off it's off you
see boom boom here's where that take to
do you understand yes so
knish just like the knife the the Palm
lost its viability the thumb took it
over at a certain point the thumb's
going to lose it that's the point where
this hand takes over do you understand
yes so I'm not going to go here on this
angle and and try to use the inside of
his
forearm again extend your arm it's not
going to change what every anything else
that I did
here you see yes again only the weirdo
iido person keeps her arm like
that so that I have the chance of a
ledge
okay well you're going drop your hand if
you
want okay does that make sense so stop
looking for those
Ledges there is a ledge but it's very
small and it's very short in its
duration okay and it happens because I
put his arm in that shape that's where
that ledge is right there you see let's
take your arm there I am on that ledge
right here where my thumb is here's my
thumb is
underneath okay here you are feel how
pronounced it
is
watch going away move your arm the other
way going away completely okay so I move
you with gon into here the ledge is PR
bounced we're moving this way do you get
it but it's very short in its duration
the thumb picks up it's get very short
in its duration but it did its job
you're going south do you see and I have
entered and the other hand takes over
the motion okay try to stop looking
for this hook
there and try to stop looking for this
anchoring
here you're going to continue the motion
around what we're
doing okay
try but
there there's there's no reason why I
need this typ trapezius ledge you see
this don't need that
if I was here or
here see Virginia you're like here okay
let's say I'm doing the rest of the
technique let's just just relax I'm
going to game it and when it comes time
to throw you this will not
offer what this will
offer you're going to have to move your
hand H that's not going to work so I'm
here on this
side my hand is
not in any
way ready to push
down I'm just on the side it's like a
harlem C game a
har it's
all one here on the side
okay let's try hand my neck
hand is
here relax
like I know that it has to
be on the side of your
neck got it that is going to be 90° to
the centrifugal energy that's how I
create the adhesion okay right I know it
doesn't have to be here anymore or here
or some weird thing here with the Trap
okay
so does that mean then that I'm here
or that I'm here no it's too far I
should feel the same exact tension free
of katad DOI pay attention cuz I changed
the wording a little bit there it's not
necessarily always the katat angle it's
the tension free of the katat my hand is
just laying here it's just laying there
okay now imagine if you're short really
short
if
I here so here's where I am for for
Andrew okay and if I move
out keep this Bend and I move
out and I move it here it's
K but I
imagine
that if I go to that kador angle and I'm
really short
that arms
extended and now you're not in Kata
dirty you're in that extension you would
feel the tension so if I'm really short
like I could get away with this on
Andrew but Virginia you might have to be
here that brought the bend back in my
elbow okay and the tension will tell you
where that is so when I touch him you
can touch him early and this will tell
you that tension will tell you where
does my Emi have to go how much do I
have to move him into the spiral or
deeper into my counter to his and this
takes us back to the other night I'm I'm
doing combinations of my hand work and
my footwork do you
see and so that I have the natural way
so my hand is very relaxed here
there's no there's no tension
there no
tension so I'm going to show you a
couple variations I move him deep into
it you
see so I
am using my hand workk my hand workk
this way that way see how far he goes
ask
me and now my footwork can change it's
very little but the hand tension does
not
change let's had work more centrifugal
energy I move him where I need to be do
you got it you can play with all that
but something that you change the
technique
[Music]
or you're
like tense and we're not doing it right
it's very
effortless
boom very effortless
okay try